the inuit reproduce their world in
miniature the egyptians in miniature the
peruvians
the human being has also constantly
reduced objects knew since childhood
which shocks the person enormously
so hello my name is dan aultman
and i am a miniaturist
a miniature c  is in the full sense of the word
it's beautiful a miniaturized situation
that is to say a situation scaled
when you build a
miniature attention to detail and it is
essential
the detail in the atmosphere you a son
which run on the ground a little bit of
dirt
the detail in the dilapidated and I see
that no element is missing
to date I have made a will say 30.37
miniature in all between scenes in 25 years
in a miniature it takes  see each other for a year
to make a miniature a full year a
lot of people think that
it's acrobatic difficult complicated
certainly you have to be very concentrated
certainly you have to be skilful certainly you
have to be patient but for me it's
always been a challenge  standard happiness
my job as a miniaturist makes me
look at the world a little different
differently from other people then
a week miniaturized
it immediately represents a
huge case of society the optical effect and
is great it's a little
deception it's  a little
prestidigitation
there is an optical effect which is
surprising
in miniaturized places there is a
gigantic world
I have often been given the word ravers
m